essa imagem ao faz parte do território
brasileiro e ela me acompanhou ao longo
de uma estrada arquitetura há sete anos
atrás quando eu cheguei no brasil há
sete anos atrás eu tinha aquela idéia de
mudar o mundo
e na verdade fui mudou muito mas procuro
imaginar e mostrou as diferenças ensino
a respeitá las
eu ensino uma abordagem nos sonhos e
poder concretizá los não gostou que pode
haver uma mudança
acho que o principal desafio é
transformar junto e modo colaborativo
eu antes de antes da minha história com
gaza e falar buscar a diretoria do galo
a gente falava que o arquiteto eu
trabalhava no escritório de arquitetura
e obrigava os meus tempos livres a
construir casas de emergência a
plantarem árvores na cidade
virtualizar praças e todos os projetos
que eu fiz parte havia uma coisa que une
a esse projeto quero fazer com as
próprias mãos
alguns saem realmente a pensar que
alguma coisa errada além eu comecei a
procurar novos caminhos
eu saí do escritório de arquitetura e
foi nessa altura que eu conheci o
conceito falado que tenha acabado de
subir no brasil
o conseg falou à rede falabella faz
parte de uma rede mundial dos
laboratórios locais que fala sobre a
democratização da tecnologia ela fala
sobre o acesso à tecnologia ao
conhecimento às ferramentas ferramentas
de fabricação digital que envolvem
emissoras 3d que envolve corta lazer
fresadora eletrônica programação várias
ferramentas uns possibilitam criar
idéias do papel foi que eu não saí
freqüentar o espaço e observei que al
ain de ferramentas além dos príncipes
típicos além dos processos que união
realmente uma revista de favores que
permitiria duplicar objetos em idéias
havia também um sendo convidados no
espírito de partilha
se vocês forem um favor a vocês vão
encontrar desde inventores engenheiros
arquitetos físicos bióticos das mais
variadas pessoas compartilham
conhecimentos compartilhar ferramentas
no processo como objetivo o vozão
digital nem formato que os trouxe os
computadores
o vovô digital nas telecomunicações que
nos trouxe internet e muita gente acha
acredita que nós estamos passando por
uma nova revolução digital nessa
aplicação das coisas que envolve muita
questão da cultura do faça você mesmo
uma cultura que permite que você
construa que você com certo você
modifica você sobre que objeto com os
vossos próprias mãos
inclusive a fabricar máquinas através de
outras máquinas água aberto software
aberto que está disponível para todo
mundo
eu vou trazer alguns exemplos alguns
exemplos não são sobre as imagens que
chegam fazem parte de toda esta rede
corporativa que envolve uma rede de
comportamento uma rede multifuncional
que impulsiona criatividade inovação nas
mais diversas áreas na educação na área
da saúde na área do meio ambiente do
desenvolvimento econômico
desenvolvimento social
o primeiro exemplo foi uma prova que nós
desenvolvemos um ano passado por um
menino de 7 anos que tenham uma formação
congênita essa prótese ela não foi feita
apenas por nós
ela foi fruto do nome dado que já
estudava sobre o próprio 3d o que nós
fizemos em conjunto com o instituto de
ortopedia e traumatologia da usp cem
anos nós não iríamos conseguir fazer o
projeto primeiro não são os médicos
depois que nós não somos especialistas
na área e por nós precisamos das outras
pessoas para conseguir construir e fazer
que ele
gente o primeiro projeto o primeiro
modelo que nós envolvemos foi de um site
chamado e não é bom
esta plataforma uma plataforma
internacional coletiva onde qualquer
pessoa pode baixar uma prótese 3d e pode
ficar disponível para qualquer pessoa
mas atenção que é necessário o
especialista é necessário alguém que o
acompanhe e consignada paragens cidade
de cada pessoa em particular
outro projeto também uma próxima neste
caso para proteger pernas é provas feita
pra pela vaga seu site e mister da em
conjunto com fábio lado de dan e uma
instituição chamada um aos 17 o fiber da
indonésia
o objetivo deste trabalho era conseguir
entender de que forma é que os países em
desenvolvimento como é um como é que a
indonésia 1 sendo um país em
desenvolvimento
consegue ser autosuficiente na
construção do trote e de forma que o
fado lado consegue assegurar e melhorar
esta produção então rumar foi uma
prótese aberta à comunidade uma prótese
feita com materiais locais neste caso o
bambu e fibras naturais fibras de árvore
de abacaxi uma própria auto ajustável
que permite que qualquer pessoa consiga
ajustar as suas cilada no meio desta
plataforma incrível nós temos uma
ferramenta que é open source o avançar
significa a livre utilização com escrita
à partilha e à melhoria contínua dos
projetos ao longo a em qualquer canto do
mundo
este livro eu falo muito sobre esta
criação coletiva e falamos no âmbito do
design
o design está vendo no design outras
variadas áreas
está havendo uma mudança do consumidor o
produtor e o design
o consumidor está ganhando cada vez um
papel mais ativo na produção que eu é
dos próprios produtos
então está surgindo um novo natura que
eu
osmar que não tem tradição português mas
que significa a junção do consumidor com
o produtor
então hoje em dia nós conseguimos baixar
um projeto à internet que demos ao
tráfico desde adaptar as nossas
necessidades quiser colocar novamente na
rede para qualquer pessoa possa usar ou
então fazemos esse objeto com os nossos
próprios não existe um movimento agora
no brasil que envolve toda esta cultura
do faça você mesmo que chama o movimento
marca está se introduzindo na educação e
as escolas cada vez mais estão se
aproximando de ritmo deu né
vamos aproximando estão tentando
entender quais são os benefícios deste
movimento e te querem construir os seus
próprios passos marcas nas escolas
não existe qualquer forma os alunos não
precisam ter acesso a sensores 3d de
ponta as mais modernas o que interessa e
valorizar a aprendizagem através da
experimentação
o que interessa e valorizar a descoberta
dos alunos e fomentar esta criatividade
eo empreendedorismo comentar isso
através do ano by doing através do
aprender fazendo esse projeto e alguma
faz parte de um favorável na índia foi
um favor que estilo na rede
internacional não funciona como um
centro experimental de pesquisa social e
tecnológica e tá aí o seu principal
objetivo é transformar os jovens rurais
e empreendedores e inovadores
então tudo que é feito lá no fábio foi
tempo os alunos que fazem parte dos
projetos dos alunos
então vai desde montar uma cadeira
montar um computador montar uma sala de
aula
outro projeto que nós fizemos pa são
concurso do bairro requer de nós
participámos em 2015
o bairro é que aquele foi um curso
desenvolvido pelo vácuo site em conjunto
também com o fabuloso deve ser dada e
tem o principal objetivo
montaram no diretório voltar para
biotecnologia pessoal
então nós é investir mais nas nossas
envolvendo oito máquinas de baixo custo
que incluiu uma incubadora em com um
microscópio em incluir um espectômetro e
outros equipamentos de baixo custo que
estão disponíveis na internet internet
pra qualquer super baixar esse exemplo e
já que estamos no rio é tão falado o
lado que tem feito alguns algumas
pendências com biópsias
então eu estou desenvolvendo e simples
através de bactérias
isto é um dos exemplos que pode ser
feito dentro de um laboratório de
biotecnologia
no caso da garagem nós começamos a
pensar de que forma é que nós podemos
replicar esse equipamento para as
escolas
nós começamos a fazer uma conta e nós
chegarmos a 100 mil reais na direção de
comprar todo este equipamento no mercado
nós gastamos 6 mil no final do ano
passado nós tivemos dificuldades em
montar um laboratório de ciências
é numa escola pública são paulo por
alguns equipamentos ea intenção
realmente que nos dessem continuidade ao
projeto envolvessem os alunos nesta
construção o seu próprio notório um deus
dependem o seu dia a dia sendo um pouco
do ambiente educacional entrando em
processo participativo 8 do território
este projeto já no produtor em seu
território no mundo
nós participamos desse projeto em são
paulo a convite da secretaria de
desenvolvimento urbano de são paulo e
olavo novel que é um laboratório de
menez novas
o objetivo deste laboratório era
desenvolver algumas oficinas junto com
os moradores da vila maria para entender
a ansiedade dos moradores para a anp
asas mapear as expectativas para a
construção de um céo queria ser a
construir nesse bairro
aí nós fizemos uma maquete em 3d com
alguns e conte também foi 3d
representava as atividades que o jatinho
grande nesse bairro e as atividades que
eles gostariam de ter
na construção do hotel do céu em uma das
alças nós fizemos com as crianças e
causa 200 foi promover que os vinhais em
os lugares interessantes e importantes
prêmios que estão aqui é o bairro com
uma alimentação com uma música com andar
de bicicleta como usar pipa e aí nós
materializamos esses dois anos para
incluir nessa maquete para provocar
novas leituras do território em voltando
um pouco o início ea minha origem que é
a arquitetura eo que fazer com as
próprias mãos
eu contei um álbum desse tempo eu tenho
pensado na prática profissional de
arquitetura e de que forma
de que forma é que estou com sete do
fado apaf conseguem contribuir para a
construção de um território mais como
motivo um exemplo deste projeto
aconteceu em portugal em almada perto de
onde eu moro então é um território
bastante me ligar pra mim eu não
participei porque estava aqui do outro
lado do mundo mas eu acompanhei todo o
processo
essa atividade é um workshop que foi
desenvolvida para que houvesse o im
uma conjugação entre investigação e
intervenção no espaço urbano no espaço
público envolvendo um processo
participativo é com os anjos dos
moradores daquele bairro
então fez uma virtualização do bairro
que envolveu alunos professores que
envolveu um falado que envolveu a
prefeitura local o centro de tecnologia
local que envolveu vários escritórios de
arquitetura e os próprios moradores do
bairro elza entre um diretamente
exigiram aos construíram junto com os
arquitetos e com todas aquelas pessoas
que estavam envolvidas no céu
esses foram alguns dos exemplos
surgiram durante o workshop mesma mas
queria mas nem imóvel um espaço para
crianças é uma mesa de convívio uma
horta urbana um espaço das suas pudessem
guardar as ferramentas que utilizavam
horta
então quando eu penso em inovação social
eu começo a pensar que parte do
princípio que o objetivo de todas essas
ferramentas que eu falei agora desde o
comportamento desde a colaboração aliado
às ferramentas de fabricação digital
plus bonita e tirar idéias fora do hotel
e materializada los
de fato salvamentos treinamento
poderosas para nos transformarmos o
nosso território para nos transformarmos
a nossa sociedade e para trás de mais de
unidade como esta aqui que eu tive
contato a 70 atrás
efe am/an